nous allons passer maintenant à quelque
chose vous allez voir de tout à fait
différent si l'on en croit un sondage
réalisé en allemagne une allemande sur
quatre roues d'un tête un homme pour ce
qui est des hommes 82 % des allemands
sont satisfaits de leur condition
8 % préféreraient appartenir à l'autre
sexe et 10% se sont déclarés sans
opinion cela m'amène presque
naturellement à vous parler d'une pièce
de théâtre qu'ils rencontrent en ce
moment un grand succès au théâtre du
palais royal à paris et qui est l'une
des pièces les plus drôles monter depuis
longtemps le couple poiret serrault qui
fête ses 20 ans sinon de ménage du moins
d'associations professionnelles n'a pas
hésité à monter un spectacle qui aurait
peut-être choquer il n'y a pas si
longtemps
pénétrons donc dans la cage aux folles
au théâtre du palais royal
pas une once de femmes mais celle de
michel serrault paseos en soirée mais
poiret et serrault dans une nouvelle
pièce un peu spécial de jean poiret
qu'est ce qui vous a décidé à écrire
cette pièce peut-être l'envi de
commémorer notre vingtième anniversaire
je les dires de mariage avec le sérum et
enfin étant donné le thème de la pièce
ça fait peut-être un peu équivoque
vas-y ma chérie ça va mais tu es vous ne
pensez pas que c'est un petit pays qui
veulent justement au bas je pense que
nous avons fait suffisamment nos preuves
l'un et l'autre pour qu'il n'y ait pas
d'équivoque
et je pense que la pièce d valable que
dans la mesure où il n'ya pas
d'équivoque sur les personnages qu'ils
interprètent les rôles ne tirez pas les
cheveux faisait d'intel qui m'amusait
parce que généralement on a l'habitude
de placer les gens normaux dans des
situations anormales
on a plutôt l'habitude de voir des
personnages occupons une position
honorable est importante dans la société
être obligé pour des raisons de votre
ville de ce maître en dames la gpe le
contre-pied j'ai pris des gens qui par
leur profession se met tant d'âmes tous
les soirs dans une maison de travestis
et étant obligé de jouer des fonctions
dites normales dit honorable c'est à
dire de jouer les bourgeois très
strictes ensuite
je vais me faire ça je couvre
mais 20 millions d'âmes
ok
selon ses membres
il faut considérer d'abord que l'aco la
pièce est une pièce très très très très
visible par tous les publics nous
voulons faire pays et nous avons fait
rire avec des messieurs qui se
travestissent come on come on peut faire
travestissent dans dans l'ain comtesse
d'escarbagnas sous ou dans d'autres ou
dans d'autres classiques ou dans
d'autres votre ville
m